agricultural implement
that was adapted to war.
This is the flail.
It was used in un-armored
fighting into the 16th century,
but we know that
the Kaiser Maximilian --
the Emperor Maximilian --
used flails almost exactly like
this in knightly
tournament fights.
Usually, the head has
a 360-degree pivot.
The physics behind that,
it can just deliver
an unbelievably hard hit.
And this shaft is so heavy that
it in itself is its own weapon.
And you'll see people
sometimes even choke up on it
and use close in...
Yes, like a little bat, yeah.
...like this.
Like a billy club, yeah.
You know,
for the most part, your hand
cannot be down here
or it's gonna get hit.
And you'll see it used
in a figure-8 kind of action.
You'll see it used
in a 360-degree
rotation clockwise,
counterclockwise.
It's, uh --
It is a mean, mean weapon.
Sinou: One of the most dangerous
features about a flail
is that it's very difficult
to defend against.
People general
use defensive, uh,
defensive postures like this,
using the haft of their weapon
or using the blade
of their weapon to defend.
-Yeah.
-This'll go -- When this hits...
Don't hit yourself.
...it'll go
right over the top.
Yeah.
And look at the range,
you know?
-Yeah.
It's still gonna hit its target,
so defensively,
you're gonna have
to really be mobile.
You're gonna have to use
your legs to get --
to get away from this.
-Yeah.
The other thing is
the sheer weight of this.
The weight and the way
the weight transfers on this,
um, if you miss a shot,
the momentum is a lot different
than what you're used to.
And this also --
Like, you just saw my hand.
As it goes around, you could
actually twist it in your hand.
♪♪
Any time you have
a flexible weapon,
they're difficult to ward
against,
to cover against,
to parry.
And in this case,
this one actually has a capacity
to hit your self
as you're swiping a blow.
-That is --
-Quite a monster.
Yeah. I would say that's--
it's an understatement.